jackie is with us Jackie's in Mount
Vernon Illinois hi Jackie how are you
I'm doing good how are you better than I
deserve what's up well my question is
about I guess baby steps three
my husband works for the railroad he's
on a traveling gang right now because he
is getting more money that way
to get us three baby step two and my
question is would it be better to do
bringing him home before baby step three
or after baby step three uh well I guess
the way I would look at it is this
number one I'm with you the goal is get
home because I had me being gone all the
time from my home and my wife is not
good for me I just don't do well I
travel a lot but I do it in one to three
day bumps and he's gone a lot more than
that yeah you come about one day a week
yeah and so that that's that's hard as a
way of life you know looking in the
future so the way Sharon and I would
measure that is kind of a cost-benefit
thing the cost is he's going to be gone
versus the benefit
how much faster would we have baby step
three done okay let me give you an
abbess are example I'll just make up
something okay let's say that by being
gone he could finish baby step one 12x
baby step three I'm sorry twelve months
faster by being gone for a month I would
do that you know but if by being gone
for twelve months he finishes it one
month faster that trade-off doesn't work
you know I'm only gaining a month and
I'm losing him from a year no I wouldn't
do that one you see what I'm saying so
it's how much the cost kinda is him
being gone and the benefit is how much
faster because he's gone and look at
that and go you know it's just it
without him gone it's only gonna if he
stays home it's something only going to
slow us down a month well then stay home
you know but if it's gonna slow us down
a year
well yeah I kind of look at that one
because you know probably probably roll
up my sleeves and rip the band-aid off
thing you know but but that that's kind
of that the cost and versus benefit
that's how I would look that's how
Sharon and I would look at it in other
words here's a know in our world it's
different than that but in our world
years ago the kids were little and I I
launched the very first national book
financial piece with a publisher and I
went on a book tour and I was gone with
little kids
I was completely gone I mean I was think
I was home one day in eight weeks
mm-hm and that was really hard on Sharon
but we knew it was only for eight weeks
and we knew if we got that book out
there and made it a best-seller that we
eat for years and years and years would
make money on that book and so the
trade-off the benefit versus the cost of
eight weeks was worth it it was an
investment into our future that was
reasonable versus the return would we
have signed up for something where we
had to where I had to be gone on the
road for the rest of my net for the next
decade and I was gone and homeland only
on weekends in order to win financially
no that was too much for us we couldn't
emotionally have done that mm-hm
you see the differences yeah we're going
on eight years right now yeah no no no
no you're not you're not been eight
years in baby-step - no even eight years
screw the reason he was on the road
before is because you were screwing up
all I'm looking at is from today forward
not how tired you are but from today
forward how much quicker is baby step to
baby step three I can't get it right
maybe some three done versus the amount
of additional time on the road right and
if it's if it's a really short time on
the road to create a really dramatic
positive result I might do it if it's a
long time on the road
to barely create a positive result I'm
not doing it okay that's how I'm looking
at a long time would be you know just
what's much right off here that's all
I'm talking about what's the trade-off
because it's an investment into your
family either way for him to be home or
for an to be on the road and make sure
you have the baby step three fully
funded emergency fund in place for those
of you that are newer listening baby
step three
is a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
grandma's rainy day fund a fully funded
rainy day fund they're out of debt
everything but our house that's what
she's sing by being done with baby step
two and now they want to keep the
intensity up maybe to finish out baby
step three or do they want to lighten up
on the road travel a little bit right
now lose some of that income and and
lengthen the amount of time it takes to
complete that emergency fund for those
of you that didn't know the code that's
what we were discussing during that call
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
Oh